for my father intelligence was all that
matters
ever since my brother Charles was
diagnosed to be a gifted child all he
talked about was IQ and intelligence
research a high IQ apparently strongly
predicts good grades a good career and
even health and mortality and stuff his
favorite story is kim yong yong a korean
with an official IQ of 210 just six
months old he was already speaking
fluent Korean and at age 3 wrote essays
in German and English then he would hug
Charles and look at me with this
question in his face I hated that I
wondered if I could reach my little
brother in anything when I was young me
and my dad were best buddies
he never even cared much about IQ or G
or whatever when my brother started
reading at just 2 years old everything
changed suddenly I was forgotten and
soon after I was the slow one once when
I got a C in math he didn't even look at
my paper and just told Charles that an
ape is believed to have an IQ of 40 I
hated his sarcasm once at dinner when he
started talking about intelligence orgy
he'd say G stands for general
intelligence and scientists say it
exists because apparently most IQ tests
correlate and whatever he was talking
about it and then drew up this graph on
a piece of paper saying look boy this is
the distribution of intelligence of all
people in town 0.1% of people will have
an IQ of 55 or below 2% have an IQ
between 55 to 70 14% between 70 and 85
34% will score between 85 and the
average which is set at a hundred
thirty-four have an IQ between 100 and
115 and 14% between 115 to 132 percent
have an IQ higher than 130 and only 0.1%
will have an IQ of a genius of 145 or
above like your little brother I told
him I'm not interested I guess I
shouldn't have he exploded not
interested you know what this all means
boy he turned the paper around and
started all over it means that if you
take the 1,000 people then one has some
form of men
retardation which means trouble living
alone 20 will have difficulty reading
the map 140 can perform simple tasks at
work but cannot qualify to become a
soldier in the US Army 340 probably
finished high school and another 340
will go to college maybe 140 can do a
PhD and later work as surgeons 20 are
capable of producing a significant
scientific work and only one will make
it into an Ivy League college like MIT
where the average IQ is 145 your little
brother got an IQ higher than that
a few weeks later was career day at my
school some people in suits showed up
and told us about a new form of
cognitive assessment we could be doing
which would help us find the right job
the technical term is the Wechsler IQ
score when I heard the words IQ I got
completely sweaty hands my heart started
racing this could be the moment of truth
then one woman started speaking she told
us that we are now going to take a test
and just 1 week later we all get the
results with some specific ideas about
our future career path she said it takes
only 90 minutes and measures our
intelligence in the following four areas
perceptual reasoning verbal
comprehension working memory and
processing speed the assessment was
voluntary and my friend instantly stood
up to leave the class showing what he
thought about this whole thing my
heart's still racing I wasn't sure what
to do and kept seated our teacher then
handed out some questions when she
passed by my table she simply said
you're gonna do fine here I don't think
she realized this but I was so happy to
hear her say that maybe I'm not all that
bad at these stupid IQ tests maybe it's
a day that I can actually show my dad
who I really am what shall I do I was so
ready to show my dad that I'm no idiot I
decided to stay
I turned the first page over it read the
following perceptual reasoning is the
ability to think and reason with visual
information it is the ability to see
what is being asked and to organize
information in our heads through images
the first question was when folded into
a cube which of the following corners
would touch corner a D be ye see I tried
to fold the cube in my head and yeah it
worked
it must be d the second section was
about working memory our ability to keep
several chunks of information in our
mind simultaneously one of the questions
was what is the next number in the
series for twelve six nine eight six
there were four options six five ten or
twelve the trick here was to put all the
digits in my head and look for a pattern
for X 6 X 8 X which means the next would
be 10 the third section was verbal
comprehension which measures our ability
to access vocabulary express ourselves
in a meaningful manner and apply
reasoning skills to information
presented verbally and the first
question it said what is the difference
between the words refuted an irrefutable
do they have similar meanings have
contradicting meanings or mean neither
the same nor the opposite they must have
contradicting meanings the fourth
section was about processing speed the
pace at which we take in new information
and make sense of it in order to prepare
a response one of the questions asked
was what is the 12th letter of the
alphabet is it t L R or B I realized I
had to rule out all the options that
didn't look right
counting would have taken way too long L
is the right answer I had completed all
of the 50 questions in time and I was
very relieved in the end the woman said
a lot of research over the last century
went into the IQ test we had just taken
and there is convincing evidence that
our intelligence is mainly a product of
our genes there is an estimate of a
heritability range from
50 to 90% although the environment also
matters
she continued especially negative
influences during your childhood like
infectious disease malnutrition air
pollution or led in the paint of your
walls at home these things can reduce
your IQ forever she explained that it's
because during the prenatal period in
early years of life a child's brain
consumes a huge part of the body's
energy to grow and if the body was under
attack it cannot support the brain's
growth to its full potential in other
words you were born with a pretty fixed
IQ good parents and schools can keep the
IQ at its genetically predefined level
and maybe increase it a bit negative
influences however can surely reduce it
a lot I am just saying this she closed
because if you are getting your results
next week and you are not happy with
your score or our recommendation the
know that there is little you can do
about that even if you practice for
years or continue school indefinitely
it's almost impossible to improve your
score by more than 10 points just think
about that before you open that envelope
you don't have to when the envelope was
handed to me a week later I got excited
to open it I took a deep breath but
before I ripped the cover apart I halted
do I really want this why do I care so
much do I really want to compete with my
brother and if so what does this prove
there are so many aspects of my life
that matter more than my measured
intelligence I'm probably no genius but
I know I did well but more importantly I
know that I don't need to prove anything
to anyone I decided not to open the
envelope and I loved this new idea of
myself free from these limitations I
felt like I had grown up now when I
heard my father speak all proud about
Charles I just smiled I realized that
it's not that he loved him more no my
brother just gave my dad the chance to
get attention to be someone he's the dad
of a genius and not just another middle
manager at the bank on middle street
a few years later I dropped out of
college and started my own company and
soon after fell in love with a wonderful
woman and also started a family my
brother is now a professor at a famous
university but never found the right
girl and like many very smart people
suffers from depression
my dad doesn't care so much about IQ
anymore he's now a proud grandfather
they say it takes intelligence to know
how to do things right but wisdom to do
the right thing leaving that envelope
closed was the best decision of my life
here are five questions from a real IQ
test you've got five seconds each when
you are done post your answers in the
comments good luck
won a package of gift cards has a length
of eight centimeters a width of four
centimeters and a volume of 64
centimeters cubed what is the height of
the box to some bar goals are chango's
and some chango's are Manhattan's are
some bar goals definitely Manhattan's
yes or no three max needed to get seven
new doors from the home improvement
store for his house his car could only
hold two doors at once
how many times did max have to visit the
store two four seven eight or nine
[Music]
for art is to wall as cup is to handle
coffee cupboard rim nail 5 what is the
missing number in the series 1 1681
blank 625 1296
[Music]
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects and simple language and
cartoons to support students all around
the world in their learning if you want
to support us you can go to WWII and
calm sprouts and donate just $1 from
many fans makes a big difference
[Music]
you